uh let's go next to ricky from charlotte
is that is that charlotte north carolina
i presume
yes it is david can you hear me i can
hear you fine
okay awesome thanks for taking my call
uh so i wanted to ask you
i've kind of noticed it seems to me like
the right
is better at
stigmatizing and demonizing
words
and certain things are associated with
the left more than the left is so just
to give like an example
um
you know for
decades they've worked on demonizing the
term socialism
and it's kind of stuck and all the like
you know left-wing sort of economic
schools of thought like you would if
you're just a normal person if you would
think that you know marxism is
synonymous with genocide or something
like that but i just don't see the the
left like as doing as good of a job as
like
you know demonizing a lot of ideas that
are associated with the white right the
only example i can think of is like
we've kind of demonized nationalism but
i kind of see that they they're trying
to revive that what do you think i
completely agree with you and you're not
the only person to notice this george
lakoff has written about this
to some extent thomas frank has written
about this um that this is you know you
go back to the very basic framing of for
example
tax relief tax relief is is evil genius
in a sense right well you relieve people
of taxes taxes are a burden it's just
taxes burden people you get rid of taxes
you relieve the burden
um that is a completely absurd and
myopic framing of the fact that
government needs to be able to do things
and we have decided that we don't do
uh in most places a private fire
department or police department and and
roads and all these different things uh
but the term tax relief at a structural
level
um pushes things in favor of the right
and the left has to argue against that
and it they've done it with socialism
they've done it with abortion you know
pro-life
um i think that there are definitely
opportunities for the left to take to
win the branding game you know one
example that
this should have started a year and a
half ago
uh these republicans who are crazy about
the pandemic either they don't want to
deal with it in a serious way whatever
they should start to be called pro virus
right they're on the side of the
coronavirus that's the way that it
should be framed and it's if i if i'm
the only one doing it it's not gonna do
anything but if that had been the
framing for a long time
um that when they do these things they
are really on the side of the virus we
may have been able to change the
trajectory even a little bit of the way
that the pandemic was dealt with i think
there are opportunities but you're
completely right that for the most part
the left is not doing well on this issue
of naming and framing
whoops i accidentally i'm sorry i
accidentally muted you there what were
you saying
can oh sorry can you hear me now yes i
can no it was my fault i apologize
no problem the i was just going to say
the one uh more recent thing that i've
noticed and it's kind of made me mad
that ever since the like social justice
protest last year yeah a bunch of these
boomer republicans for the first time
you know heard the term
woke and they've done everything to
demonize it like saying that i i i
really hate what's happened to the term
because i think back you know it's it's
not a new thing it's been around for a
while and it was always just about like
you know be conscious of uh it was about
being conscious no like history like
understand like
uh how the systems work and everything
and don't just always fall for the
mainstream narrative now you know
they've effectively demonized it to
where it just means like anything you
know that's
uh
like you know they'll call any sort of
climate change proposal woke or anything
like this and i feel like it's effective
and it's just
i i like i hate how we're losing that
battle it's the exact same thing that
happened with regressive left where
there was a very brief period where
regressive left
really meant
something or someone or an idea
that is ostensibly left
but it is actually an authoritarian
regressive thing and for a very short
period of time it actually worked to
define and point to something it then
just became bastardized by the right and
anything left they just call regressive
that's it so so yeah they they're
they're winning on all fronts on that
unfortunately
yeah well hopefully we can win it but i
appreciate you taking my call david you
have a great day thank you thank you for
calling in great uh very important issue
no question about that
um let's go next to
donny from is it pronounced v visalia
visalia how do you pronounce it
um
visalia visalia okay good where where is
that yes
it's a central california county about
uh 45 minutes south of fresno oh
beautiful area
yeah yeah um so yeah i've been trying to
get a hold of you and let you know about
uh
i suspect i'm pretty sure
that because q is the 17th letter of the
alphabet
uh and i know i heard stuff about
trump using 17 flags or something like
that but
i believe that's why he was always
saying
uh
the 1917 pandemic was to kind of send a
shot out to q supporters oh that is
fascinating let me see if i understand
this one so
q is the 17th letter of the alphabet is
that true i'm taking your word for that
i mean i haven't personally looked it up
but it was on documentaries that i had
seen the cnn
so
nopq would make it the 17th right okay q
is the 17th letter of the alphabet
i guess did trump regularly have 17
american flags on this stage or was that
like once
i had heard that well i don't know it
might have been only once i have heard
that he had did that once but i believe
that's why he kept referring to the 1918
pandemic as a 1917 pandemic that's
fascinating immediately send a shout out
to two supporters it's probably not the
case he's probably just an idiot and he
once said 1917 and then he kept saying
it because he can't admit but that's
fascinating that that's uh that that's a
signal to cue the q people that's funny
yeah
you're kind of going in and out there
donna
oh boy all right i'm gonna let you go a
very very funny uh instinct and and
suggestion
the connection left a little bit of
something to be desired there
let's be honest most health food snacks
are not very exciting they don't taste
great they don't fill you up one of our
sponsors is monk pack who makes amazing
keto granola bars that are sweet soft
chewy and filling with a slight crunch
each has only one gram of sugar two to
three net carbs and just 140 calories
perfect for anybody doing low carb or
keto or if you just want a tasty sweet
snack without the sugar
everybody should be mindful of sugar
intake but you don't have to do so at
the expense of flavor because monk pack
keto granola bars come in delicious
flavors like coconut cocoa chip peanut
butter blueberry almond vanilla there
are other flavors too i can tell you
first hand they're all great i always
keep these in my pantry it's a perfect
snack during a busy day go to
monkpack.com
link underneath this video and you'll
save 20 when you use the promo code
pacman at checkout